boy
lady the high-level feed the papa
what then
well assalamualaikum admittedly better
care to bother assisting and dear
friends welcome to this show thanks for
that Musa Muslim youtubers start to pack
everything that you need to know to be a
Muslim youtuber so we're going to start
off but before we start off guys don't
forget I need you guys once you finish
watching this video to share it with
your youtuber that you listen to don't
forget that now let's get straight to
the point I've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 point
which you'll see no I won second yeah
there you'll see sorry 8 points there
which I'm going to be covering in sha
Allah now obviously for us that that's
as you guys know there is books behind
me now just put those books behind me
does not mean this is a recitation video
or anything like that this is just a
general review it is just a general
video out there for new youtubers and
also for you guys to have a better
understanding of us youtubers and I
believe YouTube is an amazing platform
given to us by Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
because back in the days before people
will open TV and they will believe
everything they hear and not only that
you did not have another option yes a
different TV channel same rubbish now
hundred Ellis Montel has given us this
option of YouTube where people can watch
what they want when they want to watch
instead of watching TV and believing
everything they want to believe or just
being brainwashed so YouTube is a
platform given to us by all spun
Ouattara for us to take advantage of and
make the most out of it and obviously
every will single one of us are out
there to do something better for the
beneficial for the Ummah our intentions
are correct but unfortunately just
intentions being correct that the
correct way of doing it is to have
correct intentions and your actions
follow forth but anyways let's get
straight into it now I just want to go
into intentions the second point
intentions are really important before
any YouTube or anyone wants to comment
to the social platforms here or wherever
it may be why do you want to do what you
want to do this is something that is
it's really really important if you are
coming to the YouTube scene your
intentions are to to make money you need
to make those intentions clay your job
you want to make money you have that
right if you want to do that you have
that right you can go and choose to do
that you get it put in my opinion aside
yeah you want to go on YouTube and make
money you can do that how you go about
and do it is another story which we're
going to is something else we're going
to come a car come on - so you're if
your intentions are to make money you
have the free will to do that if your
intentions are to come on a social
platform and do Dawa and help the Omar
etc given the co2 the buffers and sizes
etc you have the right to do that and I
would recommend you to do that if your
intentions are to give dower and make
some money you have the right to do that
it's totally fine you want to do that
you have the free will to do that if
your intentions are to cut get on
YouTube become famous get known if that
makes you feel better you can do that
that is your free will you can do that
I'm not going Islam into this I'm just
telling you you want to do that nobody
can stop you nobody can stop you you can
do that now me personally when I want to
get into the YouTube scene me personally
I did not and I do not mean this into
sound pious or on anything special Mia I
mean I just want to protect me from
arrogance or thinking that I'm better
than anyone else you know that is
something a character that a Muslim a
believer should not have a male of
protect us from that of arrogant
behavior I wanted to do Dawa to the
non-muslims and giving us here to the
Muslim youth this was my intention and I
thought this is what I want to do now
once you have those intentions now you
take your first step now I had the
option especially at the beginning when
I started YouTube I was financially in a
bad place like really bad place I had
family issues because I was new to Islam
it was absolute madness but I could have
had the option of getting paid by
YouTube but I personally personally did
not want to now the reason why I don't
know and this is personal to me this is
other brothers who are in the Dow's in
which I know who are the same like me
and I know some good brothers and lovely
brothers mashallah may Allah bless them
who do get paid and there's nothing
wrong with that
you know but my opinion was I did not
want to why because I fought if money is
involved it would mess with my
intentions now different people deal
with that in different ways and some
people are stronger
I found myself weak on that point of
thinking okay if I do get paid it would
mess with my intentions so
my fault I don't really want to go there
so I for I don't want to get paid by
YouTube until this day hundred I prefer
not to get by get paid by YouTube and
hundred low praises belong to Allah that
financially I'm okay and I don't need
that extra money and even if I needed a
little brother sometimes do get paid by
you trying to use that to facilitate
their Dawa or their videos in the
production which like I said before
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
that this is something that was personal
to me but if you've gone into that into
with the intentions you're a Muslim
you've gone in there with intentions of
making money or for fame like I said
before for fame then that is not a big
problem for you because I think maybe
that's the least of your worries
however as a brother of course I'm not a
like I said you have the free will to do
what you want I'm going to conversate
you can't do this can't do that
islamically going and making money out
of it as long as you're not doing
nothing haram if you are not doing
nothing Haram nobody can come and see to
you you can't do this if you for example
let me give a beautiful broth of mine
Musa as an example
brother Musa started off doing Dawa then
afterwards he liked it I know mostly
like to be creative and stuff like that
so we thought look this is I want to do
vlogs and I said it's a good idea
because you're young even though Musa he
does look a bit oily looks like a 40
year old no offence most of you watching
this but he's young he's 18 19 side we
new 16 he's 19 now sake what you doing
is perfect you know as long as you're
not doing nothing wrong which you don't
doing vlogs and giving general reminders
because that's what the you fight your
age does showing them because all all
youth go out doing club' and all kind of
madness but Musa is doing vlogs and just
given general reminders and live in his
way living in hell are we given reminds
and I thought that it's absolutely
nothing wrong however if you're going
with intentions of getting Fame
then I would say to renew your
intentions because fame a lot of people
want it but believe me something that
you really don't want to and especially
if you are a Muslim and if you're going
especially if you're a Muslim you need
to understand even if you don't go out
there doing down put that to a side you
going out there with the name of you're
a Muslim that's going to cause problems
because people are going to have
expectations my brother or my sister so
you need to really understand that now
let's move on let's talk about new
youtubers people coming into the YouTube
see new now
it is good that we should have more
youtubers it's good it's good for the
dawa it's good that we can show put
positivity and etc which I agree with
but it is very very crucial that we
understand that being a youtuber comes
with with responsibilities so now these
two linked new youtubers and the
responsibilities of futures I'm going to
cover these both at once inshallah now
as a new youtuber is easy get a camera
record yourself whatever you do these
days people just vlog in their life
whatever it may be you just become a
youtuber instantly now what we need to
understand balance is it's very simple
it's very easy get a camera you're a
youtuber but what we fail to understand
and is so sad is that once you become a
youtuber and people and unfortunately
people look up to us and genuinely like
I'm in the YouTube scene and this is the
reason why I'm doing this video to give
you guys a background and understanding
for for both the new youtubers and for
those who are watching our stuff to
understand where they're coming from is
that look you need to understand when
you're a new youtuber
people will start looking up to now I am
sometimes I get treated like I'm
something special but this is what
YouTube comes with I didn't choose this
the work that all I wanted to do for the
sake of Allah brought that with it now
sometimes my intention goes up and down
this is something that's really big but
what you need to understand is if you're
a new youtuber you can't just say let me
get a camera record myself that's it I
can do whatever I like like I said
before you have the free will to do
whatever you want you do as you please
but what you need to understand is it
comes with a responsibility if for
example you are youtuber and then in
your social platforms or in YouTube you
start swearing you start using foul
language you start using racist terms
towards other people what you need to
understand is that people are looking up
to you so when they look at you and this
comes with you you can't say hey I don't
want them to look up to you but it comes
along with it it's attached we need to
be careful how we conduct our self in
public as much as we can and this why
this is the reason why Providence is
it's such an crucial topic I would
HIGHLY and brother Haile did a video on
this matter as well
and even though
I love him I genuinely amazing before
met him he's a good buffer
I like the stuff but the fact that he
said that everyone should do you - I
just disagreed with that with a buffer
but he's too humble right we went to eat
like a couple of days ago we talked
about it it's just he agreed but what it
is my brothers and sisters is that what
you need to understand is if every Tom
Dick and Harry gets on the YouTube
platform like I said before you have the
free will - but what you understand is
if you don't understand the
responsibility that comes with it what
you're going to do is you're going to
end up misguided people there is so many
people out there who do absolutely
disgusting videos absolutely disgusting
videos like I don't want to go into it
and you need to understand people are
looking up to them and people are
thinking are there something special or
they're doing something right so that's
why one thing that I will advise you is
that look and this one advice I get is
that look make yourself free from me
with media touch yourself yes see me as
a good bother etc but the moment you see
me doing something wrong do not think
that is right don't think just because
it's Ally and I love him and I like his
videos or whatever he may be or his
Turkish and I like kebabs he's Turkish
he they make kebabs so that means what
he does is right no you might like
kebabs I might be Turkish there's a
connection there but what I do is wrong
so you should detach yourself from me as
a person this is why it's so important I
want to give you guys in the region of
the prophet sallallaahu Sela when a
Sahaba came and said o rasulallah do we
get rewarded when we have intimate
relationship with our wives he said of
course just as you get a sin when you're
in a Haram relationship and just as
during a haram relationship and you
commit zina
that is a sin when you do it the halal
way you get a reward work for being
intimate with your wife kissing her
whatever it may be do come to being kind
to her you get rewarded so I want you
guys to understand something here here
I'm going to link this hadith with the
youtubers what we need to understand is
that if you're just as if you're you
commented YouTube seen for fame or
whatever it may be and you start
misguiding people because there's a
responsibility
on your shoulders your YouTube are
people looking up to you if you start
misguiding people you are going to be
blamed for that so this is something we
need to understand so before you get
into the scene you need to understand
this so you're going to go out there and
then you're going to start misguiding
people and every person that you
misguide you are going to be blameworthy
off because you are telling them for
example do this or do that you're
showing for example let's say you're
going out then you're like hey I'm with
my girlfriend or hey this that what
you're doing is now you are putting it
into the people's mind okay I'm a Muslim
I kind of a girlfriend - you are going
to be blameworthy for putting that out
there now just as the way that when you
do something wrong and you miss guiding
people you get sins when you call people
too good the prophets allah salallahu
hollywood seldom said whoever caused
anyone too good will get the reward
they're off of every good babe that they
do so when you do something bad just as
you get a sin when you do something good
you get a reward and also for the
rewards that you get other people to do
yes like I said before you are free do a
youtube video do whatever you like but
know that brothers and sisters on the
day of judgment every single thing that
you did is going to be is going to be
brought in front of you and that is very
dangerous because when there's one
person you guys who watch us when you
guys do a symbol between you and Allah
it's between you and Allah let's say you
did that scene in public a hundred
people saw is between you and I'll an
hundred you expose it to hundred people
but when we do a mistake now if it's
obviously genuinely we did not mean to
inshallah font Allah forgives us but if
I'm intentionally going out there and
saying I'm going to do a video calling
people to go and get girlfriends and
commit dinner or whatever for example
steal money or whatever it may be then
you need to understand then you need to
understand is that you are going to be
getting the sin of how many people watch
the videos roughly look I'm not even
that of a big youtuber 100,000 views
over a certain period amount ah
there are people out there who get
millions of views can you imagine 1
million people watching a video and
after 1 million a little percentage of
200 people think that's ok
go on commit Xena you are accountable
for that so this is why this is the
reason why I wanted to expand on this a
little bit more now let's move on okay
let's move on why I don't associate
myself with everybody now this is a
topic for new Muslim youtubers to really
keep an open ear for this please yeah
you can do this with it is and you can
listen inshallah sorry I am working on
my job as a bit dead now guys
Association is very important now I'm in
the YouTube seen people look up to me
like I'm something special but I'm not
this comes along with it like I said
before now I need to be very very
careful who I work with though I have a
responsibility of who I work with now if
I'm a youtuber I'm known to be in the
dour scene I can't go and work with
somebody else for example let's say some
brother is a new youtuber he just comes
up I have to do I have to do my
intelligence I need to go and look what
the brother is doing is he doing like
I'm not I'm not like going to hump
listen hey let me catch my no no just to
see what the wiser brother doing ok ok
good ok
so when I see a brother for example he
starts swearing he starts backbiting
he starts promoting things that are not
permissible Islamically now I will have
a big responsibility on my shoulder if I
can't see here let me go work with him I
go and work with him two months down the
line if he turns around and says oh I
for example
I'm gonna go clubbing now you need to
understand people gonna go hey hold on a
second brother Ali dad was chili with
him so damage brother and he's cool with
him he's going clubbing so brother Ali
Dawa must be cool with going coming
because why would it be friends with
someone I'm trying to say so this is the
reason why it's so so crucial as a
youtuber is so important for me to know
who I'm working with now example I'm
gonna give it and I've asked about the
permission is well may Allah bless him
his brother Khalid he's a new youtuber
and I follow this stuff you know and
obviously I follow this stuff and I
personally found a brother sincere I
found him sincere I found his luck his
add up on point his manners how he
conducts himself like me
a blessing obviously I know he's gonna
be watching this getting gassed himself
right yeah whatever baby yeah he's gonna
be going to be excited I'm a blessed man
I shouldn't be praising him like that
but obviously I have to be truthful the
brothers and me like keeping firm on
that may Allah keep him firm on that
yeah now I personally believe music is
Haram
I personally music Azeroth yeah so I
spoke to brother Herod met brother
Khalid and we was planning on doing a
video now before I did this video and
the brother knows this work I said look
aqui yeah you're my brother I love you
in the dome above I love you if you need
anything whatever I will try my best to
help you but in the public scene aqui we
need to understand something that I said
should occur do you believe music is
permissible and this is not me saying
hey you need to believe that this is
just seen look aqui I believe it's
impermissible what's your opinion
because if we're gonna work together and
you don't mind using music then what
happens is not that you're a bad person
but if you think that is correct and you
want to put that out then people are
going to think okay music is okay
brother Ali welcome Judy I'm Janice a
and we came to an agreement
etc and I thought a key I have no
problem working with you yeah I have no
problem working with you and being seen
with you in a social platform why
because I have done my search I've
looked into it just as me when I did
when I was doing the when I when I
wanted to do the video with Mufti mink
yeah I did a couple of months ago before
I did that I got in contact with his
cousin and obviously the buffer said he
did a research with me for one year one
whole year he was watching my stuff what
I'm doing then obviously all praise me
long time I'm not anything special money
for okay the brother is doing something
good whatever it may be
okay then they gave me the permission
duty I'm trying to say so I'm not trying
to be seen here like I'm this guy who
gives permission who I work with on
something special no but the same is
done with me so that's why association
is so important hope you guys understand
okay the last two points is basically
don't take from any youtuber what does
this mean now guys what you need to
understand is that I am NOT a share a
share on his own is somebody that's
knowledgeable he was given his life to
Islam I am NOT that not any any youtuber
is not that yeah okay obviously there is
a fair share cons on YouTube then either
YouTube or us a share expound make sense
but what you need to understand is the
matter of religion and this is my
personal opinion this is my personal
opinion take it or leave it
the matters of religion
throwing fatwas around or for example
saying Haram or halal
my opinion is that look don't take from
me if I come to you and say to you the
issues of faith yeah I can't come and
say to you I believe this ruling is a
halal and I have the evidence so you
believe that whatever it may be
if I come and sit down like I'm planning
doing that for example let's say with a
certain topic of student mode with chef
- I am planning or sitting down with the
chef and do any Q&A with him asking him
but if you see me coming out there and
saying for example I read this book or I
looked into this or I spoke with the
chef and he told me this that don't take
my word if I sit down with the chef and
I'm doing the tuning with the chef I'm
conveying to you what he's telling me
then you're listening you dismiss listen
- I'm just conveying I'm just the guy in
the middle go to the people the scholars
yeah the scholars and when I mean
scholars we're not talking to every Tom
Dick and Harry yeah go to scholars the
chef people that have given their life
to this but taking nothing that comes
from me or any Tom Dick and Harry this
is why this is my opinion and this is
what I want to tell you guys the last
point there is two extremes one extreme
is harsh
everything is haram is Haram the only
word they know is Haram Haram Haram
Haram Haram Haram is it all wrong none
of us are perfect yeah so I believe that
is one totally extreme which certain
group sex do that yes now we have
another extreme this extreme is hey we
can do as we like nobody can say nothing
yeah basically hey I'm gonna go have a
girlfriend it's going to be on my vlog
you can't tell me what to do Haram
police it's halal everything is allowed
to him so we have one side everything is
Haram we have the other extreme
everything is halal so this is the two
extremes abstain from take the middle
path okay guys we went through the eight
points hope you guys have benefited
don't forget before you guys go share
this video with your youtuber hope they
can benefit this was a reminder to
myself first share it with them don't
forget we've started a new channel
called halal dining which we go around
restaurants or all around the world and
we
we check how how loud they are etc
except to do check the channel out just
type in hello dining don't forget to
share this video with every youtuber
that you know inshallah they will
benefit because it was a reminder to
myself first that's about it for me I've
a beautiful day inshallah take care of
yourself guys
assalamu alaikum what happened to me
better care too